special holiday edition of the needs and
no first we're calling today the needs
of snow or the need to hohoho I'm Erik
Bosse joining me at the table I love you
make them Sam basher over here
jurisdiction of any kind well on this
show we like to dive deep in all the
biggest news each week but guys we're
gonna bring some holiday cheer to this
nerdy roundup we're drinking eggnog
these three decide to wear silly
Christmas outfits and didn't tell me and
I brought the head of my enemy we assume
all of you are wearing your holiday
outfits right now are you yeah why don't
you tweet us pictures of you no you know
that's not a good idea to ask people to
be pictures themselves you don't have oh
my god what have I done well today in
the need to go care lane maybe we're
gonna lead off with a new rock stars
edition of a thing I'm calling naughty
or nice as old man 2017 rubs just sleepy
eyes and tucks himself in it's time for
us to review this year's highs and lows
right the movies TV other nerdy events
that filled us with joy but also the
ones that left us annoyed bit of a rhyme
I wanted to rhyme the whole time I'm
still doing it just a bit so I thought
we could each share our naughty and nice
just do it once don't do it twice oh
what's one thing that happened this year
that was nice for fans both for all the
women's and all the man's the one thing
that you found to be very very naughty
but nothing too dirty that belongs in
the
yeah so what do you guys think what was
the naughtiest this year what was an
isis year for you I don't think a lot of
people would put themselves through this
oh man it's tight actually may I put two
yeah cuz they tie you don't have you
been naughty oh nice
that in humans TV series and the fifth
installment of the transformer series a
man answered a phone call yeah I
reviewed it a man answered a phone call
in the theater and I've never been
lesson I've met I didn't care I was more
interested in what he was talking about
with his podiatrist and what was
happening on the screen with Optimus
Prime a doctor who works with feet trash
hurt me yeah but what was something nice
for you humans did you get through it I
can't complete a lot of projects but I
sure complete most Marvel ones and I
watched all that what was the best part
about Inhumans and what's the worst
there's this point when Karnak split a
bullet in the air with his hand but then
it murdered someone next to him and then
that had no consequences later leases
repercussions nevermind
no I didn't matter at all that sure
didn't matter at all anyway so thing
that I liked thing that was really cool
for me was that I I - things Justice
League wasn't that bad for me so that
was kind of a treat and also I finally
enjoyed I really enjoyed Star Wars Thank
You mr. Ryan Johnson and wonderful
people for at Lucas films for that
personal gift yes yeah it was just for
me my naughty and nice from this year is
both happened in one movie right so I
love spider-man homecoming I thought is
very very nice it was the personal
homecoming in many ways for me I wanna I
didn't suit my home but you know but
whatever the naughty thing about it was
why the hell did they put in eight years
later at the after the opening scene it
screwed up the timeline it made a lot of
extra work for
sorry I'm very mad we still have answers
to it what a confusing thing why did
they it's so just to clarify the
timeline that event at the opening
prologue of spider-man hokum is
happening right after the events of the
Avengers which as we know happens in
2012 then the rest of the movie supposed
to be happening after a civil war which
as we know happens in 2016
why does eight years later don't tell me
it's Doctor Strange screwing with the
times a time stone and infinity war cuz
it'd be a really weird thing to do just
to fix some dumb thing that Sony
probably put him in look I'm pretty mad
16 yeah he would also be dead like 20
yeah there's a lot of there's a lot of
issues with it right anyway that's just
my naughty and nice when could an iron
spider a villain who's the true
blue-collar villain whose problems we
relate to a really fun gang Kili
inspired friend greed greed oh but you
talk about vulture eugene tooms's well
he was that's right he was pretty loaded
once we saw his house it was real nice
for the first act of the movie it seemed
like he was just a guy working a
blue-collar job like the rest of us from
marvel thank you Merry Christmas
yeah my dc-based actually my naughty and
my nice buy another nice one but my
naughty is not Justice League as some
people might think it is it's actually
Ben Affleck as a whole so Ben Affleck
signed on to be Batman and he pretty
much said that he would bring this
character back and he was going to
direct his own standalone film and he
was going to be the next Batman now he
doesn't really feel like it want to like
when you don't online shop when you're
drunk on wine at night I'm gonna make
director myself I'm gonna make my own
Batmobile right now this Christmas
what's on the eggnog so yeah I'm a
little bit disappointed because I think
that more than anything DC really does
need someone who is all in who is super
invested
and that's you know maybe sort of
relieving Zack Snyder just from a little
bit of storytelling cuz it's been a very
busy guy and he said you know how the
whole thing happened with some Justice
League so yeah I think when you put it
all on one person's shoulders that's why
there is a brother says two of them you
know yeah
so yeah I'm yeah benefics minority but
my nice is Wonder Woman Wonder Woman was
a film that delivered so much and it not
only made superhero movies the genre
really refreshing but it challenged a
whole new timeline and time period which
I thought was great with world--well one
and it also you know put women female
directors and a female superhero really
on the map know and everyone thought
that a standalone female Supergirl would
bomb which is why we never saw her Black
Widow but yeah totally totally and what
a pleasant surprise to like I owe them
it going into it I didn't have high
hopes just based off of DC use track
record yeah nothing to do with the
property itself but man going into it oh
what a delight everything was fun gal
gadot is maybe tearful happy reasons and
sad reasons I don't think it's been a
long time since of tear up for a happy
reasons yeah yeah pressive it was great
I'll keep mine brief I put myself on the
naughty list cuz I lied to my nephew and
told him rogue one wasn't a Star Wars
movie cuz he said he hated Star Wars and
I said you want to go see a movie about
spaceships and explosions and robots and
he was like yeah if I see any Star Wars
I'm leaving and I said I'm a grown-up
who's paying for this you will stay
seated
[Music]
22:39 in the end he gave the movie a 2
out of 10 but k2s Oh a 10 out of 10 so I
feel like when Vader shows up he was he
just thought it was a cameo time kids
anyway my nice I think the crisis on
Earth X crossover event for DC TV was so
much better than last year's really
convoluted confusing crossover event
that was kind of like a we're gonna make
you watch legends of tomorrow and
Supergirl so that you have to understand
it this one I was like oh they're not
making you really have to like you just
want to watch the four episodes I mean
cuz it's a fun what happened I loved it
it's the multiverse the there's a
universe out there where the Nazis won
World War two and they found a breach to
earth they want to invade our earth and
they have evil suit they have not some
Supergirl Nazi arrow and reverse-flash
and they they come over to our earth
it's very scary and it leads they make
firestorm they give Victor Garber I send
off and they they give an amazing story
for Jax Franz I'm not forgetting his
last but something like that and they
they proves that they both have amazing
they're both amazing actors and I cried
like a baby it was a it was amazing it
was amazing event I love that was a
surprise nice and that's you actually
you did a video on that I even watched
the breakdown of it there's there's so
many hidden little nuggets in there it's
very very good and you don't have to
watch tomorrow no you you get it they
set it up and you get it and they do it
in a way that's not convoluted you had
to know every little bit here's a side
supporting like recurring guest star
from legends of tomorrow showing up on
the crossover a little hint
Supergirl sister has a one-night stand
with Sarah from arrow and it's amazing
and it's like they don't they don't work
together but since they're two very cool
LGBT characters you think they'll work
together but they don't it's a great
writing it's amazing storytelling beat
yeah that's great well let us know in
the comments down below and tweet us at
new rockstars telling us you're naughty
and nice of the year 2017
and I can't say naughty without like
trying to imbue it with sexual tension
on to this week's trivia question it
looks like this week's trivia question
is all about the theme of naughty and
nice good same way could've been better
person who wrote this talking point but
the classic episode of Futurama Xmas
story introduces the terrifying robots
Santa Claus a killer robot who returns
to Earth on Christmas Eve every year to
murder everyone on his naughty list
which is pretty much everyone
what famous actor originally voiced
Santa Claus robot Santa Claus on on
Futurama
I guess it's originally because bender
voice actor John DiMaggio is also does
right did the voice when he returned but
there was another more famous actor what
famous actor actor not voice actor actor
it says actor originally voiced robot
Santa Claus from Futurama which I've
seen all of maybe two episodes up oh
you're missing out oh it's amazing if
new rock stars is around in the in the
late 90s early 2000s and honestly it's
the show was still on now right yeah we
would be breaking down 1999 these came
out in 1999 yeah this episode
okay it's like a surprise it's like a
it's someone you wouldn't know I'm gonna
go with it
well as always the one who gets the
closest answer as revealed by our judges
will get to do our sign off goodbyes at
the end of the episode and they can do
whatever dumb voice or amazing new
character they're trying out you have to
read our other news wrap-up headlines
and be hilarious on the spot sorry in
advance
moving on guys for an ex festive story
recently sophie Turner who plays Sansa
Stark on Game of Thrones revealed in an
interview I did well she recently
revealed an interview that she that she
and the rest of the game of Thrones cast
read the scripts for the season 8
episodes in the final episode Turner
described the experience as quote very
very bittersweet unquote saying that
everyone burst into tears the moment end
of Game of Thrones was read aloud she
also said this quote all of us have
always had discussions about theories
about what we think is gonna happen
who's gonna die who is going to end up
ruling now we know it feels like another
one of our theories it just doesn't feel
like that's actually what's happening
it's very satisfying so I thought we
could play along with the Game of
Thrones cast because I like to pretend
like there might the fact that it's
bittersweet for these people because
they've been in the show for more than
half of their lives right so it's like
saying goodbye to a high school that
lasted 11 years right it's gonna have to
end different so I wonder how it was a
Dave David DB & DB yeah DB D because the
books are ending with george RR martin
getting halfway through the last one and
dying of a heart attack
yeah yeah mina system
the person who transcribes from BC like
help call 9-1-1 oh you don't want me to
write this darkness let's warm ourselves
up during these winds of winter with our
dreams of spring you guys like that with
this wishlist segment let's share each
of our perfect endings our idealized
ending to the game of Thrones that
aren't just George or Martin crying for
help if this were a puppet show of
fanfiction guys how would we end it what
do you want to see I'm gonna be honest
we thought you were the holiday Santa
that we hired for the party so I am
let's set the stage for the final three
minutes of Game of Thrones what I like
to call the first three minutes of a
connected universe so magical people's
balls will come out of their eyes so Jon
Snow is staring at a bassinet with a
child freshly born of Daenerys Targaryen
it is their love child it is a forbidden
child it is a deathly gravely ill child
and it looks as though the happiness of
this family unit is about to be fracture
to the core when rumblings can be heard
all around everyone runs outside a
spaceship lands it's the Millennium
Falcon to be continued the writers the
Game of Thrones are freaking out right
now kids you just spoiled exactly
between the night king and she's new
dragon and the two remaining dragons and
then Denny and Jon side by side it is
the song of Fire and Ice showdown again
I'm so obsessed with like the two sides
running at each other it's gonna be like
that's gonna be explosion it's gonna be
good so yeah it's gonna be John and
Danny side by side well if I gonna lose
another dragon mhm
Tyrion Wiggin dead I think Tyrians gonna
make it I mean III powered through all
of Game of Thrones this summer and I had
like by the end of it I was so obsessed
with it I like I try to plan it all out
it's all escaping right now but I
remember what I wanted I wanted to
happen I wanted Tyrion to survive and I
think we're gonna lose one of the we're
in lose John or Dany or both and leave
like like Tyrion yeah we're gonna leave
the lovechild that's such a weird thing
that normal people are saying I know but
it's just this I wish our favorite
characters are related so it's okay that
they're having one of those javelins
from the night king of one of the
extreme okay they flung it and it landed
just above Tyrians head so any other
I swore I'd like it if they both if they
both ended like that was their send-off
for whatever and you get them going on
their boat to the neverland of whatever
and the Lord of the Rings whatever you
do you do some kind of grand send-off
for both of the characters you get the
kid going on to be the King you have
Tyrion being the right-hand person and
Jamie I want him to just be happy in any
way but he's gonna die also everyone's
gonna die my idea for it is I think
Tyrion is gonna live I think that baby
that we saw Jon just plant in his aunt
is gonna be born I think both his
parents are gonna be gone and I think
the baby is gonna come out of the womb
with little tyrion style legs and it's
gonna be the dwarf is the next heir to
the Iron Throne and term it's not my
think I don't want to take this universe
merged with Game of Thrones would be
unstoppable how you would like Game of
Thrones to end the it was interesting it
sophie Turner said bittersweet because
it is the term george RR martin has used
to describe how he intends the ending to
be so maybe that's just like anyway
moving on i thought we could look at
2017 by the numbers guys and i think
it's very telling a very telling number
about how we spend our time this year is
140 million 140 million is the number of
hours per day people around the world
watched on Netflix yeah the streaming
Goliath released some fun 2017
viewership numbers which but always it
really rare for Netflix normally they're
hush-hush about their shows exact
ratings they know they don't want us to
know for like because they don't worry
about advertising they're all up there
secrecy with our algorithms what not
some other fun facts include one person
watched Pirates of the Caribbean
the curse of the Black Pearl 365 days in
a row with the show the show that people
devoured the most they said that means
watch the most in a single day was
American vandal that's the true crime
mockumentary and the show that people
were most likely to watch ahead of their
significant others was narcos and the
show that people were most likely to
watch with as a family was stranger
things exactly unless you consider you
know Bob and Steve Harrington to be the
mother and father that family at which I
do right anyway what was each of your
favorite thing that you watched this
year binge the sear on Netflix I'd
recommend I recommend new girl I got
into that I caught up with it it's I
think it's the best comedy that's on TV
right now fighting me about it
it's one of the best written best improv
and the in the characters are amazing
yeah that's me personally for me I mean
the ones that were mentioned here are
all things that I really really loved
especially American vandal the the
documentary of called Jim and Andy does
Jim Carrey playing Andy Kaufman in the
movie man of the moon they have behind
the scenes footage that Jim Carrey
insisted to record during the movie and
you see his like method acting because
Andy Kaufman if you don't know was like
this famous inspirational performance
artist comedian who kind of I created
anti comedy or meta comedy
everyone likes to consider themselves
the next Andy Kaufman including probably
Jim Carrey at some point but to see Jim
Carrey do this take of Auntie Kaufman
was like such an enlightening experience
to see why Jim Carrey has been a bit and
kind of unhinged lately been a bit kind
of out there right now what are we doing
here what do we all do he's still showed
up we're in a nice suit also no one
wanted Jim Carrey I wasn't like what he
gonna do
my favorite thing to watch on Netflix
this year was the kittens crawling in
front of the Yule Log you just said that
loop when it calls 9-1-1 mine hunter was
really great we actually doing a wrap-up
of all of our favorite TV and movies
I've made sure to include mine hunter
just last year we haven't sure though
Punisher though it's a secret little
easter egg if you guys were on the fence
about it go check it out it's the most
solid Netflix Marvel show I think
they've made yeah I'm going through a
mine it's kind of nice to go down memory
lane
I watched new senior season of magicians
which is cool
finished off Sherlock which was great
dark matter it was alright Riverdale a
big fan of I wash mine I liked it I
really dug sensei it's like basically
where they all there's about eight
people all around the world that can tap
into each other's thoughts and friends
from college did I see that comedy no
Cobie Smulders and keegan-michael key
there it is I kind of liked it it was
good I was also very sick
that entire week a week from tonight
December 29th make sure I can't wait
they are they are
yeah oh my goodness and there's a black
and white one that I'm so excited for
boy okay moving on to our needs no
lightning round your questions that you
have for each of us
and I'm gonna ask all of us these
questions starting with mod who do you
think should play a young Princess Leia
if Leia does appear in the Han Solo
movie Daenerys Emilia Clarke and it
actually looked a little bit Sebastian
stand next to Luke Skywalker and that is
that's pretty cool perfect someone oh
gosh she's gonna rack my brain there was
a side by side with a young Leia and it
was spot-on Alicia vikander Kalani
Tatiana maslany so I can actually pause
to Google and find out the real answer
yes test you know miss lani would be
great that's great she does every rule
and she can do British well
Thomas Bechtel best on-screen couple Oh
Ricardo wants to know these two crazy
kids trying to make it right I would say
my best on-screen couple this year was
oh man it was Luke Skywalker milking the
green milk out of that walrus thing like
he was gonna take it straight from the
teat if Rey wasn't there he was just
we're both a giving and both getting
something out is purely mutual a sip
descent ah wants to know Oh
from what I know this is probably Wonder
Bread I'm the tax guy of the knew of the
Republic who lifting pens around what a
job for that kid nothing there's like
three little blades of grass get back to
work counted three and then Dallas wants
to know for me what music do you listen
to turn on this is what I do i turn on
my local NPR station and if people
aren't talking I turn it off and put on
a podcast that's the music I listen to
the intro music leading into to the
daily podcast hysteria
here's what else you need to know yeah
thank you for fitness questions okay now
comes the time for our 15 seconds shout
out where each of us has 15 seconds to
shout out plug I ramble about anything
we want okay 15 seconds it's a holiday
time I'm gonna rewatch shout out
everyone loves us already but sanchita
pero you want a little positive time
during the holiday season watch some
sanjana pero it's beautiful i-it's the
only thing I've ever watched ever that
makes me weep just uncontrollably but
good tears season three of yeah so
fantastic um okay so my shoutout I watch
this I'm going to start watching this
every year on the holidays 1996 Patti
LaBelle sang at the National Christmas
Tree Lighting over on the white house
and there's a technical error where the
band starts playing and I never stop her
background singers do not show up and
she just makes it work and she just has
to invent the words because she doesn't
really know and the person with her cue
cards running behind you and her boys is
great it made me fall in love with Patti
LaBelle to give a shout out to a veteran
who's in the band and she is going to be
I'm watching or have watched if I'm
alone in my pajamas
here in Hollywood and it's a pajama
party but home alone on Christmas that's
great yeah my shout out is just a nice
call to action and this holiday season
tip people well people that have to work
around Christmas I mean as someone who's
worked on Christmas Day before it means
so much more if you're just not a cheap
[ __ ]
sorry jerk so yeah if you have the money
give them a decent tip if you don't have
the money I don't know just be nice to
him then you can't spell presents with
that since since 8 yeah on Netflix
alright well let us move on to the
trivia question that we asked about
earlier okay so the question just to
remind you guys in Futurama what famous
actor originally voiced the Santa Clara
bot Santa Claus from Xmas all right
Maude said Bruce Willis
[Music]
sam says bob hoskins it was a surprise i
remember it's a surprise person yeah I
am poppin oh hell right well he's an
actor as well he's been in veep and
stuff alright so our answer is oh yes
John Goodman Bob Hoskins is the closest
[Music]
fry and Bender I'm gonna talk like this
and that constitute okay well the winner
will do our goodbyes and making fun of
our names the Twitter handles however
you like mr. bachelor but first we're
gonna quickly run through some of the
other news headlines said we didn't have
time for this week and bottom-line
Bechtold as the loser the trivia
question you're gonna have to read these
and at the end of these mine make a
little joke great okay take it away
according to the Dish Network diehard
was one of the most watched movies on
Christmas Eve last year beating out home
alone and the Santa Clause if you have
enough time to watch die hard at
Christmas by yourself you must be hard
to kill but you will die alone Forbes
listed Mark Wahlberg as the most
overpaid actor last year making 68
million dollars from his movies which
was more than the worldwide box office
total of his movie Patriots day none of
that money went to the blind man that he
beat up as a child that we just terrible
person he was Logan director James
Mangold weighed in on Disney's buyout of
Fox's film studio concerned about the
potential lack of future r-rated
superhero movies in favor of ones that
can sell happy meals and action figures
very OnPoint James Mangold these movies
are for adults and should not be enjoyed
by children a magical man who can heal
fast in half claws made of knives should
only be viewed by people over 18 thank
you for having the right perspective
because god forbid any child enjoy the
magic of comic books you pretentious
[ __ ]
Justice League despite being considered
a box-office bomb has gone on to make
over 650 million dollars worldwide
making it the most profitable box office
bomb in history the second most
profitable box office bomb was the bomb
at the end of inglourious basterds that
killed Hitler but not him because I
still think that was a response all
right Sam what's the Christmas spirit I
want to be nice so I'm when I go ahead
and read up their names and then
everyone say something that you've been
working on or that you're proud of and
they're just a shout out so I'll start
over with Tommy at Tommy Bechtel on
Twitter
all right thanks Tommy back told you can
watch me in the final season of the
middle this year on ABC really that's
amazing well Maude Garrett at Maude
Garrett on Twitter I've been working on
a video series called the SModcast
[Music]
available on my youtube channel geek
balm but you can jump over to his only
she would answer his patreon to listen
to it if you are like Eric and need to
listen to words and then the EA Voss
Eric wanna be on the camera if you live
in the LA area come to the iOS theater
to watch some very funny improv and
sketch comedy you can be there on
Tuesday nights anneal Seany
gotta be over 21 though sorry kids oh
well as Sam bachelors me small cats go
check that out because fun we answer
your questions also I do only stupid
answers is the best damn podcast you can
put your ears into okay it's a
never-ending how are people gonna go to
a comedy theater that's 21 and over when
they're gonna be so busy watching
r-rated movies movies aren't for us now
the comedian's comment down below and
tweet us at new rock stars using the
hashtag Nev now like this video share it
around subscribe to new rock starts or
deep dives into stuff you love thank you
so much I will be watching
Erik turds in them and I'm proud